first of all the the year of the flood
is about a future in which due to a
man-made virus to which nobody has any
immunity the human population has
dwindled to almost nothing and of course
in books like this it can never be
really nothing because we have to have
somebody whose story were following
people ask me in it's the science
fiction or what is it and I say well you
can think of all science fiction there's
a great big banner and then you can
think of subsets and the science fiction
proper subset involves things that we
can't do right now such as being in a
galaxy far far away
speculative fiction involves things that
we can do right now so I would call my
book speculative fiction stretched a bit
it's made from components that we
already have but those are pushed
forward into the future and expanded a
lot of my Twitter followers send me
strange science stories that they think
fit in with my book and I have to say
there are more and more of them coming
along and we do now have the ability to
do a man-made virus and we certainly
have the ability to to change or morph
viruses that we already have that is
scary will anyone deploy this you can't
actually deploy it unless you're willing
to take out your own side so people
doing biological warfare plans and of
course there are some have to take that
into consideration and probably unless
you wanted to self destruct you wouldn't
do that unless you already developed an
antidote for yourself so the question is
is there going to be anybody both
knowledgeable enough and angry enough at
the human race to do that that's a big
question and I am NOT the only person
who has thought that this might
the impossibility bottom line is we've
got the tools good part is we've had
atomic bombs for many decades now and we
have not yet blown up the planet with
them
okay I think there's there's two kinds
of things there's two kinds of novels
under discussion here one is the dopey
ax which is the combination of utopia
and dystopia generally they they turn
out to be pretty much almost the same
thing and the other one is what you call
them an apocalypse so one is about
controlled societies the other is about
total breakdown and you're talking about
the total breakdown thing it seems to be
so that they often come at turns of
centuries but they also often come when
people have have suddenly realized that
things may not necessarily go on along
the same set of assumptions that they
have been going on for the last little
while so I think was kicked off these
ones is the realization that that global
warming is here and is already having
consequences and we're going to have to
either adapt to those consequences or
they're going to be some pretty horrific
social consequences social and
environmental consequences which turn
out to be connected at the hip